the end of Frasier back in 2004 hasn't
exactly stopped Jane Leeves who played
Daphne on the show from working
consistently in Hollywood from her
animated film and voice work to the next
generation of television comedies here's
what she's been up to over the years
leaves is arguably best known for her
role on Frasier as Daphne moon a
physical therapist who truly believed
she has psychic powers oh wait a minute
I'm getting something on you psychic
we've decided to find it charming leaves
became a household name during her time
on the series picking up Emmy and Golden
Globe nominations throughout the show's
run off-screen Frasier turned leaves
into the highest paid British actress at
the time while on-screen viewers became
extraordinarily invested in Daphne's
romantic relationship with Niles crane
Frazier's brother this relationship is
developed while she lives in the cranes
apartment as a caretaker to their father
Martin despite the fact that Niles is
married when they first meet though some
critics weren't as enamored with the
relationship it helped sell leaves as a
romantic lead and when the show ended in
2004 the finale was well received
leaving leaves in the rest of the main
cast in a prime position to pursue
whichever projects they wanted to tackle
next having become a TV star leaves
opted for a relatively modest slate of
film and television work following her
Fraser breakthrough using her
distinctive voice and now famous British
accent leaves lent her voice to a number
of animated films beginning with the
stop-motion film James and the Giant
Peach in 1996 based on Rahl dolls famous
children's novel peach featured leaves
as mrs. ladybug one of James's insect
friends alongside big names like Susan
Sarandon Richard Dreyfuss and David
Thewlis her next animated role was a
return to television in the Penguins of
Madagascar series where she played Lulu
the chimp for two episodes in both 2009
and 2011 she followed this up with
recurring and varied voice work on
Phineas and Ferb where she appeared as
Wanda acronym one of the leaders of the
organization without a cool acronym
she's in charge of a secret agent that
also happens to be someone's pet
Chihuahua it's kind of a weird show
during Frazier's run leaves booked a
role in 1999's music of the heart a
feature film based on the true story of
Roberta gaspari a crusader for music
education within New York City's public
schools who pioneered music as a source
of inspiration and stability for at-risk
youth
goodbye wes craven the film was
nominated for a handful of Academy
Awards and was well received by critics
in 2002 leaves made her Broadway debut
taking over for Molly Ringwald in the
long-running show cabaret she also
appeared in the 2003 film the event a
low-budget indie that premiered at
Sundance two standing ovations thanks to
their success on Frasier leaves and her
fellow female lead peri gilpin decided
to take charge of their own Hollywood
fates and start their own production
company the two subsequently founded
bristol city's which leaves later
confessed was named after a dirty
cockney rhyme the company's most notable
project was intended to be the American
remake of the popular and beloved
British series The Vicar of Dibley which
the two produced in 2007 the original
which ran for four years in the 1990s on
BBC one focused on a small fictional
English village called Dibley and its
female vicar with star Kirstie Alley and
producer Richard Curtis on board it
seemed a surefire success but Fox sadly
ended up passing on the pilot mm oo
leaves maintain a steady presence on
television beginning with a two-episode
arc on Desperate Housewives as a
therapist who helps Lynette and Tom with
their relationship problems much more
recently she's also appeared on Fox's
medical drama the resident becoming a
series regular for the second season as
orthopedic surgeon dr. KITT Voss however
her biggest post Fraser gig has
undoubtedly been her leading role on Hot
in Cleveland as joy Scroggs a
40-something former eyebrow artist to
the stars the series which aired on TV
Land for 128 episodes between 2010 and
2015 also starred leaves as Fraser
co-star Wendie Malick and told the story
of four best friends from Los Angeles
who end up making a new life in
Cleveland former fraser stars peri
gilpin and John Mahoney also
guest-starred on the show which was well
received
earning sag and Primetime Emmy
nominations and wins throughout its run
in 1996 leaves married a television
executive named Marshall Tobin and when
she became pregnant with their first
child
Isabella during her time on Frasier the
writers adapted quickly writing her
pregnancy into a plot that found the
character gaining weight thanks to her
stressful relationship with Niles the
couple's second child Finn was born in
2003 leaves his pregnancy being a part
of Frasier isn't the only impact that
the show had on her family life peri
gilpin and leaves have been close
friends for a number of years and not
only was Gilpin present at the birth of
Leafs daughter which is all
so Isabella's godmother and leaves his
godmother to Gilpin's daughter Stella
the two former co-workers even live next
door to each other when leaves his son
Finn was born she named John Mahoney and
david Hyde Pierce as his Godfather's
turn him over if he starts fussing will
your dad know i'm role playing dad try
playing the role of a sane person huh
clearly the relationships on fraser went
far beyond the set itself and began
relationships between the cast members
that would go on to become the
foundations for a real life family check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]